want to get the one up and your
opponent's went ultra street fighter 4
launches this june capcom community
manager and street fighter pro david
hines gives us his tips and favorite
combos for ultras five new characters
here's what he's got to say about poison
poisons grinding she has a whole variety
of different tools she's got projectiles
she's got kind of Dragon Punch s mu
she's got her wrecker moves which kind
of hints you of a riding crop now if
that hits you can do it three times in a
row however the e x version you get a
fourth pit which launches them up into
the air right this is great because you
guys need to alter one offer it
nice
so this is a really great hit confirm
away for her two lands that ultra one
combo do some pretty decent damage so
just everyone so everyone knows what I'm
doing there it's a DX or decreasing
quarter circle back up two punches right
and then you repeatedly do that over and
over again and that's why I hit some up
into the air that is too poor cycles
forward and all three punches to get the
ultra now she's also got a flip kick
move this one this can go over fireballs
pretty pretty well he x versions really
fast if this just hits and you press
kick again you can turn it into a graph
that's pretty cool now again with ultra
combo w have access to both alters now
we've seen her ultra one which is a
projectile and her ultra combo to is
actually a command grab right so you
have to be really close to your opponent
quite a good seal Hugo be such a big guy
as you can see there she gives you a
nice swift kick to the nuts ok so for
poison I would say you're going to look
to try and get a hit confirm or a
crouching like it right this is a good
combo code be crouching like it standing
like it standing medium kick into her
wrecker attacks
that's going to do some pretty good
damage yeah it's a nice little combo and
the thing I like about is it you can
start it from a light crouching light
attack so again you have to be crouching
to bloggers and when you're jumping at
your opponent you might give might use
our overhead attack which is for the
median punch so they're crouching you're
going to get hit by that yeah so you
might annoy them about a couple of times
maybe use this move obviously you're
throwing your tricky fireballs out and
then you just happen to get a nice nice
little tap you'll go for a crouching
like spam crouching like click standing
like kick standing medium kick into the
reco you might even want to end it with
the ex Bible or something like that